next on book tv historian nick salvatore
documents the life of eugene debs 19th
century leader of the u.s socialist
party and a five-time presidential
candidate the first edition of this book
was published in eighty two
this is an hour twenty minutes
nick salvatore is the maurice and hinda
newfield founders professor of
industrial and labor relations
and um
and professor of american studies at
cornell university he did his graduate
work at the university of california
berkeley and came to cornell in 1981.
he's the author of we all got history
the memory books of amos weber which
received the new england history
association's outstanding book prize his
third biography singing in a strange
land c.l franklin the black church and
the transformation of america examined
the life of one of the most influential
preachers of his generation in the
afro-baptist tradition
nick is has also edited a number of
books most recently faith and
the historian catholic perspectives he
has twice received fellowships from the
national endowment of the art of the
humanities
and was a a senior fellow in residence
at the institute for the advanced study
of religion at yale university
today
nick will be discussing the 25th
anniversary edition of his book eugene v
debs citizen and socialist which when
first published in 1982 received
columbia university's bancroft prize in
american history and the john h dunning
prize from the american historical
association so please join me in giving
a warm welcome to my very dear friend
nick salvatore
[Applause]
thank you very much for that really
sweet and kind introduction
um
today i i want to talk about eugene debs
and the american tradition of descent
and some might ask
well wait a minute now why
do you want to talk about debs why
should we be reading and thinking about
debs america's most prominent socialist
uh
given today's
quite different political climate
neither socialism the communism have any
major followings in the world
and the disintegration of the soviet
union has made even those beliefs seem
to many rather quaint
in the in in current generation
then two over the last 30 years
of domestic politics in the united
states we've witnessed a growth of
conservative political of a political
move conservative political movement
that has really influenced both major
political parties so what of what
interests then would this gene debs be
who was born in the middle of the 19th
century in 1855
and died very early in the 20th century
in 1926.
well an examination i think of his life
in korea uh suggests uh uh that uh an
understanding of some of the major
changes i think that transformed america
during his own lifetime
and which still in many ways affect us
today
but also they are an examination of his
life in korea offers really surprisingly
relevant observations about our own time
as well
first i think maybe a brief biographical
scratch sketch may just kind of give a
sense of context and where uh
who he where he came from
he was born in 1855 in terre haute
indiana a bustling midwestern town with
very very high expectations uh for its
future
his parents were alsatian immigrants
and they had be they became in the
decade of the 1850s and 60s the
successful small business owners they
were retail grocers essentially
debs attended private school and then
the public grammar school in terre haute
uh for uh during uh the 1860s and one
year of the local public high school and
then he did go to work but at the age of
14 but at the same time he continued for
three years going taking evening classes
in a local business college
certain traits about gene debs were
evident really early in his youth
he believed as so many others around him
did deeply in the concept of individual
effort in individual initiative
and in education as a key to some kind
of future success
attached to this idea about about both
individualism and and taking
responsibility for one's oneself and
one's work
was the idea that there were no
permanent barriers that existed between
any given
individual and those with higher social
standing at the moment
that debs understood from his culture
and in his youth was in fact the essence
of america's democratic promise
he also received
another trait that was evident even
earlier in these years was uh his
ambiguous and yet also serious
relationship with religion
he received an eighth grade from his
high school his eighth grade teacher
abby flagg
for winning the perfect score and
spelling for the semester a bible and in
which he inscribed read and obey and of
course gene debs later as the socialist
as the socialist would would every
anytime anybody brought that up would it
would immediately say i didn't either
but in point of fact he did
uh he did read it he and as we'll see he
is evident in almost every speech he
gave as a socialist
but more than that debs at the age of 13
or 14
was a emerging young man the concept of
teenagers still didn't exist in american
culture really at that time he was an
emerging young man who grew to maturity
in an evangelically charged culture
religious revival throughout the midwest
in terre haute as elsewhere
was a constant experience in
local and even in in town as well as in
city life
and throughout
his formative early years
indeed um deb's experienced the
civil war as a young child with the
parades of soldiers in the um
uh
through the downtown the uh celebrations
of the july 4th independence day and
other events
when a battle was won by the union
forces etc and each of those
celebrations and the whole concern about
the civil war was itself encased in a
kind of a millennial sensibility a
millennial expectation uh certainly for
for the for the northern side the union
side feeling that this was indeed they
were doing god's work in in in holding
trying to hold the union together if not
necessarily
looking to eliminate slavery
but then even even further
within his own personal life
his mother was a catholic his father was
a protestant and debs as a kid began to
experiment with both churches
it's also true of both faiths it's also
true that his father was deeply embedded
in an enlightenment tradition and indeed
debs is named after eugenie sue and
victor hugo the two of of of uh uh
daniel debb's uh gene's father two of
his most favorite uh uh novelists
so after working after leaving high
school he went to work as a paint
scraper literally cleaning the old
peeling paint off engines in the
railroad yards in preparation for a new
coat of paint
and then in the depression that began in
1873 gene debs was laid off uh from his
job
and
he went on to
travel out to east st louis illinois and
looking for work
and it was at that time for the i think
for the first time or at least the first
time that we know of that yet another
essential quality that would inform much
of his adult life became obvious even as
a child as a young man
he wrote his sister in in the fall of
1874
that he didn't plan to stay away any st
louis forever
but he planned to stay away long enough
he said and i quote
to prove that i can act manly when must
be
now that concept of manly in this
pre-freudian society has a different
ring and a different meaning
than it might in our own time today
it certainly involved personal
responsibility it's certain revol it
certainly involved a sense of uh
one's character and the virtue that one
hoped was embedded in that character
and so it did have many of those
personal but decidedly pre-freudian
connotations
but it also carried with it a concept of
a communal set of responsibilities that
one was an individual but an individual
who lived in this particular community
this particular society terre haute
indiana beyond that the larger reality
of the united states
there was indeed in the thinking and
framing and the social dimension of this
concept of manhood in debs's
understanding as well as in others
there was a sense that
he had a commitment to a larger
democratic community to retain to
develop and to preserve
the traditions that he would later talk
eloquently about as coming down from the
declaration of independence and coming
down through the constitution of the
united states and particularly in many
instances of course to the to the bill
of rights for the bill of rights now
one of the things this meant then that
even as a young man in 1870 75 a 20 year
old
a guy
when he joined the brotherhood of
locomotive firemen which was an early
form of working-class organization uh at
that time what decidedly not a union um
and he became the local recording
secretary for the terre haute lodge it
really was not surprising that he
opposed publicly vividly and actively
the 1877 railroad strikes in terre haute
but also the strikes that had begun in
west virginia and ultimately would
travel across
the united states over two to three week
period to san francisco
he opposed him because he felt that the
the the class anger that was being
expressed by some was a violation of the
basic trust
the basic uh sense of community what
bound the values that bound the
community together
and
that because it it brought in that class
element which at the time he argued was
an antithetical to a democratic uh uh uh
ethos that was he argued or thought was
supposed to be the structure of the
society
it was also not surprising given these
attitudes that in the into the mid 1880s
gene debs would welcome with open arms
of development of the corporation as a
major form new form of economic
organization
when in 1870 the
pennsylvania railroad first established
its
uh a nationwide rail system under one
own under the ownership of one firm um
that began a whole transformation
not just in the railroad industry but in
fact in in the very nature of industrial
of of of
production uh in general because to
create that national system you had to
have that with headquarters say in in
this case in philadelphia you had to
have a system in place
that would make certain that the
coal or the
wood that you needed to fire the engine
the food or the water you needed for the
passengers etc
was in place in cheyenne wyoming for the
502 going out to denver so you had to
develop a whole bureaucratic structure
to be to allow supervisors or vice
presidents if you will in in
philadelphia to have all of that in
place
this signaled in really a fundamental
way
in 18 when it occurred in 1870 this
really signaled that the beginning of a
major transformation of of both economic
uh structure the way we the society
produces goods provides services and in
fact most fundamentally the very nature
of work itself
because no longer with family uh
companies whether in the railroad
industry or any other industry no longer
were family organizations going to be
the ones that were structuring the
nature of work it was going to be a
bureaucratic process
and you you might never really see
the actual individual who makes the
final decision as a worker and indeed we
will see that that i mean we know in our
own lives that that structure continues
on uh in in the process of consumption
as well so that you've got a very new
way of dealing
but at first debs looked at this and saw
this uh he welcomed these corporations
because he thought that they would
actually be helping
to develop and and to further further
encourage
the very concept of social mobility that
he saw as inherent in that small
community in terre haute
it was also not surprising and not
surprising that given these attitudes
that debs very quickly began to get
involved in local politics as a democrat
uh and also began to become quite
popular he was elected to the city
council in 1879 reelected in 1881 and
then in 1885 won election to the uh
state assembly in indianapolis
he was in the in the words of one of the
local terre haute newspapers the blue
eyed boy of destiny and indeed that's
how he was seen
uh and uh that's how i might also add
that's how he saw himself
uh
he talked proudly uh in later years if
with some sarcasm given the way his
career actually evolved he talked
proudly of
that in 1885 after he won a decisive
victory for the state assembly that
people were talking of him as
a candidate for congress in a in after a
little bit more seasoning and the talk
was in the newspapers that he would win
the uh eighth congressional district
quite easily
but something happened to him on the way
to congress if as it were and he be and
in the mid 1880s his thinking began to
change
and it changed particularly about the
nature of the corporation
he began to understand that the
cooperation with whatever benefits it
brought in terms of efficiencies of
of production etc that what it also
brought with it in the very inherent in
its very structure was a concentrated
economic power that had an impact on
individual citizens
both as workers
in those
industries but also as citizens
that if the single most important
metaphor and end
fact
of that american democratic tradition as
debs and so many others understood it at
this time
it was in fact the right to vote the
ballot which uh was held by many as a
sacred obligation to exercise each time
um
what was the relationship of the meaning
and the value of that ballot and that
democratic tradition
debs began to query and to wonder and to
write editorials in the local in the
brotherhood of locomotive fireman's new
magazine
what was the influence of these
corporations on the ability to maintain
that individual democrat connection to
democracy
what uh
uh as mark twain called this era the
great barbecue what did that right to
vote mean
when corporations
could buy as mark twain put it could buy
congresses and state houses uh uh quite
easily
and he began then to begin to rethink
the the the emphasis he had given or the
welcome he had given not so much to that
it would the problem was necessarily he
thought corporations the problem was the
way in which they used their power that
there was no countervailing force there
was no way in which a simple individual
could say
stop
this is harmful to the to our community
because there was such an imbalance of
power
by the 1890s eugene debs began to argue
then
for the that what was needed was a
stronger more effective voice
for non-elite non-corporate if you will
people
that what was needed was a way to unify
individual citizens without losing that
sense of individualism
if you will but to unify
individual citizens
in a way so that they could begin to act
in a collective fashion to address
problems that were not simply theirs as
individuals but in fact was structurally
embedded in the transformation that they
were experiencing as a group
so in the early 1890s he
began to move away from the both the
brotherhood of locomotive firemen as
well as some of the early trade unions
which were built on skilled whatever
your skilled craft was carpenters were
in the carpenters union plumbers in the
plumbers union etc and he created in the
railroad industry an organization known
as the american railway union
and this was the uh intended to be
the a
industrial union that is a union that
brings all workers in the given industry
into the same union regardless of what
level of skill they might have
in unity the slogan went there would be
strength
and
debs also began to argue and to to to
write about that it would be through
industrial unionism we would the the the
the the effort to provide a
countervailing force to the unilateral
power of the corporation it would be
through industrial unionism he argued
that in fact america would be able to
preserve in an industrial age its
fundamental commitment to democracy and
so industrial unionism and industrial
democracy began to
connect be connected in debs's writing
and in his thinking
because he argued what might seem to be
para a paradox but in fact it was really
the heart of what he his his agitation
really was about
the only way to maintain the value of
individual citizenship in a corporate
society was to find some way to bridge
the gap between
a individualism that was understood as
isolating and even aggressive
and a a finding a bridge to from that
individualism to an understanding of the
of of the society as much more of a
communal effort that had to have
somewhere at its core an understanding
of a common good
the american railroad union went on
strike in 1894 against the pullman
corporation
a the makers of the pullman sleeping
cause which no longer exists but up
until the 19 late 1960s were a major way
in which america americans traveled long
distances on on the trains
the strike was essentially paralyzed the
railroads from to the west of chicago
the eastern railroads were not generally
affected and debs this is the point
where debs begins to become a major
national figure because in fact
uh in one of many uh uh uh um examples
of this
in harper's magazine during the summer
of 1890 there was a picture of gene devs
wearing a king's crown with debs on the
front of it sitting on a trestle
railroad trestle bridge which is open so
indicating that the trains can't pass
and commerce can't pass and indeed it's
it's the it's king deb's preventing
american prosperity is essentially the
theme of the of the cartoon or the the
full-page uh portrait but indeed what
what was most important about the the
why debs rose to begin to become a
a well-known figure was actually the the
he refused
to
heed the warnings of the managers of the
railroads that were affected in the
strike he refused to heed the warnings
of the attorney general of the united
states who appointed as a
u.s special district attorney
for the strike a man who until the week
before had in fact been the chief legal
counsel for the uh railroads themselves
um and as a result debs and some of his
co-leaders uh ended up getting um
charged with contempt of court and were
uh sentenced to uh debs was sentenced to
a six-month jail sentence and his the
the other leaders of the union were
sentenced to a four-month jail sentence
it's when he comes out of jail that he
be he's where he's had plenty of time to
think and also to talk with all sorts of
folks who came to visit him at woodstock
county jail
just outs outside of chicago
it's when he comes out of jail that he
then he begins to assume
an even more public and
forceful position as a dissenter
to
the transformations especially
concerning the nature of the power and
who holds the power that were
america was undergoing at that time
he came out of jail in november of 1895
the train took him from woodstock to
battery d in chicago where he was met by
what the newspapers report in a a crowd
of over a hundred thousand people
whether that in fact is true uh one
can't say but nonetheless it was a large
crowd
in the speech he gave which would begin
really would be a classic deb speech
that would last until he's his death in
1926 the themes of it he declared the
declaration of independence and the
constitution of the united states that
they remained yet despite what had
happened in the pullman strike they
remained yet the core of american
liberty and the pride of an american
identity despite and i quote being
mutilated and torn and flung aside as a
thing of contempt by corporations who
know the price of price of judges
legislators and public officials as
certainly as armor a major meat packer
knows the price of pork and mutton
it was a payon to american liberty it
was a pay on to american democratic
values and he quoted liberally
a poem
ship of state from the poet james
russell lowell
it's only two years after that that gene
debs declares himself a socialist in
1897 and will begin a long career as a
socialist where he would run for
president for five times on the
socialist party ticket
and in 1912 would gain some six percent
of the popular vote certainly the
largest vote that a socialist candidate
has ever received in the united states
not i don't
i know not the largest vote that a
third-party candidate has received but
um but what's really important to
remember and to think about
uh in terms of gene debs is is that in
1897 he was 42 years old
he was a mature man he was not born a
socialist he was not born a radical and
he didn't give up or reject american
democratic traditions when he became a
socialist and when he became a radical
rather his socialist beliefs
would remain grounded in america's
democratic promise
and he saw in socialism
a fulfillment of those american values
in the context of the technologically
driven corporate world that america was
in the process of becoming
to kind of develop that just a little
bit more and to talk about
three i what i think are really central
characteristics of the adult debs
let me talk first about
his understanding and the meaning of
individualism
deb's never rejected that concept of
the individual being at the center of
american democratic processes nor did he
reject individualism
as a some kind of a guiding value of for
americans
but as i suggested before he recognized
the need to create a bridge from an
isolated eve and an aggressive
individualism an individualism that that
emphasized accumulation for that
individual regardless of the price or
the cost to others
a individualism that was not dissimilar
from
the survive concept of the social
concept of the survival of the fittest
that you needed to build a bridge from
one sense of oneself as an individual
to a renewed commitment of a common good
um
and he gave this idea classic expression
in a speech that he
he gave the one i'm going to quote from
is in 1910 in utah but in point of fact
he gave this became part of his stock
speech
he said repeatedly he said i am not a
labor leader this would be to large
audiences of working people of
people who were
coming to hear the socialist agitator
speak perhaps coming to think about
joining the party certainly debs was
attempting to organize people in these
speeches
he said
i am not a labor leader
i don't want you to follow me or anyone
else if you're looking for moses to lead
you you'll stay right where you are
i wouldn't lead you into the promised
land if i could because if i could lead
you in
somebody else will lead you out
you must use your heads as well as your
hands
and get yourself out of your present
condition
this is not exactly the most common
approach that an american politician
running for the presidency is going to
take
um
but it is deeply reflective
of gene debs's commitment
and belief that a democratic socialism
would in fact nurture and maintain
democratic values
in this changed nation and changed
culture
debs was mistaken
in thinking that the corporations as he
did
uh thinking that the corporations would
somehow be a vehicle in the in preparing
the way for a transformation to some
kind of democratic socialism
um
he he argued that as many uh in the
socialist party and in the progressive
party uh did as well
argued that the corporations with their
concentration of resources their ability
to create efficiencies of scale and
production of goods etc therefore
lowering prices and the like that he
hoped that they would be providing the
infrastructure that would then in some
moment in some future time
when
democratic socialism he thought was in
fact voted in
uh through the ballot um
would
would be in place for a new
use of that power by democratic
socialists this turned out to be
not only mistaken but rather naive
but in this again debs was a poor
strategist
uh and we we would not really look to
eugene debs as as a political strategist
in thinking through a a a an economic
plan
um because but and also like so many in
his own in his own era they had not yet
fully grasped the full extent of the
transformation that the nation was in
fact undergoing
but what remains at the core is some
understanding of the need to speak
to the individual through that process
of american democracy
the second characteristic i want to just
mention is
debs
found out and in fact was not really
deeply surprised by
that there was a compatibility
with this socialist movement
or of the socialist movement with a
large-scale evangelical movement that
was growing to maturity and strength
even at the same time debs was running
for president of the united states
now debs himself was never religious as
an adult uh he uh uh
never went to church uh except when he
got married in 1885 but uh he was a
decided atheist and and
never
never
preached to convert anybody to any type
of religious faith
but the tone and structure of his
speeches
reflect deeply the the the the
influences both from terre haute and the
midwest and then ultimately uh those
influences as they permeated so much of
american society in the in the early
20th century
as the quote about the promised land
indicates biblical imagery infused debs
speeches
um
he talked about jesus christ he talked
about
both old and new testament the promised
land he talked he would quote from the
prophets at times
also as that quote i read before about
the promised land and i'm not a labor
leader suggests
debs although he was giving a decidedly
secular
speech
understood intimately the structure
of the revival sermon he was calling for
a personal conversion
he was not he was saying don't follow me
you have to think this through
you have to come to that sensibility
yourself because what we need he
continued to always seem to argue what
we need is a
committed
group of individuals who understand that
the need to find a way to what uh to a a
common good to what he would call a
democratic
uh
socialism indeed some of debs's greatest
speeches the most well-received speeches
uh
occurred
actually in the south and the southwest
as one part and there too there was
great strength of the socialist movement
where indeed
that area was already being deeply
affected by the growth of an evangelical
movement from the 1890s on first the
holiness and then the fundamentalist
movement
and indeed stanley clark the state chair
of the texas socialist party proudly and
repeatedly announced himself as the
leading biblical scholar on socialism
and he was the leader of one of the
largest socialist parties in the in the
united states now what is ironic about
this and what is befuddling about this
when you think about it
is is that the one other area of strong
socialist strength with at times not
always but with at times a religious
tone to it as well was amongst jewish
immigrants in the lower east side of new
york in milwaukee and elsewhere
as one
non-english-speaking
member of one of debs's audiences once
put it
he said he was asked by a reporter in in
polish i believe he was asked by a
reporter how do we
you don't understand what anything debs
is saying devs was talking for two hours
and this man said to him in his own
language he said
deb speaks to us from his heart and with
his hands
that's all i need to know
well
in a very real way there were when debs
would speak in new york
jewish women came with bowls and i'm not
making any of this up stereotypical as
it may sound jewish women came with
bowls of chicken soup
uh as far as i know nobody came
suggesting that they should that he
should come they had a daughter at home
as far as i know but but but they came
with bowls of chicken soup they adopted
debs and there were they were literally
uh
socialist party uh divisions or parts of
socialist party clubs in the lower east
side that took it as their
responsibility to to to nurture him and
to if you will mother him
um uh when he was was there um he had a
way
of touching people
partly because i think embedded in him
was indeed an evangelical sensibility i
don't mean not in a religious sense but
what i mean is is that he understood
the way the the the
his own beliefs would were deeply framed
in a fashion that allowed him to speak
literally from his heart as well as with
his mind but to speak in a way that
affected people um
who had come perhaps to hear a
more uh a a political talk and found
that they were being moved on multiple
levels now for some of his more orthodox
comrades and uh who were more orthodox
marxists they groaned whenever this
occurred they groaned whenever debs
spoke of christ
of christ the working man
when he evoked god's blessings on
america's promise when he infused his
socialist speeches with all sorts of
biblical imagery and the like and when
he praised those social gospel reformers
the reformers who will be motivated by a
liberal protestantism because indeed the
the traditional socialist critique was
is that um
they only went halfway they only were
partially understood social problems
debs did this this talking of of in
religious language in terms
even as he castigated churches for their
failure to attack the causes of poverty
even as he continued to argue that uh
socialism needed to really transform uh
uh
to to work in in obviously overtly
secular and economic ways to transform
uh amer american life
so there was a connection there and
there was a connection that was
reciprocated by some not all by any
means but by some in the evangelical
movement of the earliest 20th century
that is a connection that we don't quite
necessarily see in our own time today
but there is indeed it was indeed that
possibility
in
in of connecting from evangelicalism to
a
a
a more uh
overtly secular political movement
third area i just want to mention third
characteristic really is the meaning of
dissent understood through gene
as i've suggested his dissent really
comes from a core commitment to maintain
democratic values
uh he stated that in uh that speech in
1895 when he came out of a woodstock
jail he said he said the right
to vote or in that right to vote
lay the power and i quote to repair the
judicial dagger holes in the
constitution made for the accommodation
of millionaires and corporations through
which they drive their foreign hands a
horse-drawn wagon they drive their
foreign hands as if they were cumberland
gaps
he evoked that same tradition
23 years later in 1918
in canton ohio
when in the middle of world war one
he defended anti-war protesters and
anti-war dissenters
some of whose broad political vision he
sharply disagreed with
from the attacks by the federal and
state governments but especially by the
federal government
in that speech at canton ohio he evoked
tom paine jefferson garrison lincoln
among many others
in support of the proposition that those
who who uh who rejected a false
patriotism and therefore became
dissenters were the most indeed the most
patriotic and the most substantial
citizens in the nation they were the
ones who had the nation's interests at
heart in the most deepest and
fundamental way
for giving this speech he never once
suggested that young men should resist
the draft but in giving that he had at
other times but he didn't in this speech
for giving this speech woodrow wilson
the president of the united states who
had defended free speech in his
electoral campaign in 1912 and 1916
the wilshire wilson justice departments
indicted him for violation of the
espionage act that had been recently
passed
a trial ensued in september of 1918 in
cleveland ohio and debs in the manner of
political prisoners worldwide refused to
let his lawyers offer a defense
and instead addressed the jury himself
he noted that there were famous
revolutionaries washington payne and
adams among others
all of whom would have been executed as
felons
had the revolution failed
he recalled the abolitionists who worked
so hard against slavery elijah lovejoy
who lost his life
garrison thaddeus stevens and many
others
and he reminded the jurors
that in american schools at the very day
that he was being tried
in american schools teachers teach our
children um
and rightly so he said to revere their
memories
even as the government of the united
states
acts
to imprison those who are walking in
that tradition
for his part he said he affirmed a wider
patriotism
one that understood
even encouraged dissent
as a way of helping the nation
come to a better understanding of its
possibilities
one that upheld a diverse understanding
of what it meant to be an american
and rejected official or simply
elite-led definitions
of what it meant to to to be american
he affirmed that whiter patriotism one
that applauded the individualism at the
heart of the culture
which understood its potential power in
the vote
but which also grasped the need
to bridge from that individualism to
join with other citizens in concerted
collective action
to defend basic rights and values
the judge
then
sentenced debs or after the after excuse
me after the the jury
found him guilty and the judge sentenced
debs to 10 years in prison at
federal prison at atlanta federal
penitentiary
it is not
an accident or a metaphor
but an actual fact
that the only picture that gene debs in
his early 60s had in his prison cell at
atlanta federal penitentiary was a
picture of the contorted visit visage
of the crucified christ crowned with
thorns
part of this was indeed perhaps a a um
a bit of melodrama in terms of the
analogy to himself
part of it was
again reflected a deep understanding in
him
of
uh the way in which the larger culture
of the nation had affected him and was
in indeed part of him
debs ran for president the last time in
1920 as prisoner number 9456 at atlanta
federal penitentiary
in their wisdom and and graciousness the
wilson administration allowed him one
press release a week
and he did indeed though receive um uh
delegations from the social national
socialist party to quote-unquote plan uh
strategy
gene debs received of just under a
million votes some nine hundred thousand
and something votes
about three percent of the actual vote
in 1920 because 1920 of course was the
first year that women were allowed to
vote in the uh presidential election uh
and and so there was a a a a much larger
electorate
when he left prison he was he served two
and a half years in atlanta president
warren camille hauden who succeeded uh
wilson wanted to um
see him wanted to meet him actually and
so he
arranged for debs they already agreed to
uh he had agreed to a pardon arranged
for devs to get on the train and come on
up to washington
no guards etc
and um
as debs left the prison there was a was
then a long winding circular
driveway i guess we'd call walkway i
guess we'd call it
um
the warden in the prison
released the prisoners
from the jail their jail cells i assume
maybe not all of them but but but the
story is
and they came to the front inside the
building but they came to the front
of the building
because debs had made such an impact on
so many of them over the course of the
two years that he had been in atlanta
federal penitentiary
as i've suggested debs uh is perhaps not
the person we would look to as a
political strategist
but i think his real value
in his own time
and in
and for us in the tradition that comes
down
from his time two hours resides in a few
things it resides in his
ability i think to articulate from
deeply within american political culture
and to defend them
the values without which
he argued the political transfer the the
the profound transformation the nation
had undergone
would in fact undermine the very culture
and the society itself
that if in the process to becoming a
full-scale industrial power
the nation lost its understanding of and
commitment to
those fundamental in right democratic
rights as embedded in the declaration of
independence and the constitution
we may have the riches to use the
biblical analogy but it would have been
for naught
debs i don't think can speak to our
circumstances today
he remains
but he does remain a potent example of a
dissenter working to preserve and
broaden
our vision of american possibilities
then as now one can disagree with
specifics
but the act of dissent itself
whether in the hands of a debs
a martin luther king
a rosa parks
a dan berrigan
and many many many many others
is really at the heart
of the american experiment and at the
center
of the process that maintains its
vitality
thanks
there is plenty of time for questions
but could you just uh speak to
to uh mike is holding the mic and
after any questions
um a question about i have a question
about um
uh deb's use or employment of religious
metaphors or the social gospel as you
call it
um do you think uh he would have been
more effective as say martin luther king
was if he were a believer as opposed to
an atheist who was simply speaking
metaphorically and and would someone of
that ilk be more effective today
than say a standard socialist atheist
well
i think gene debs was was looking to
lead and form a movement that was
broader
uh in the sense of more diverse i mean
there were plenty of atheists there were
there were plenty of
of just
agnostics as well as a great diversity
of religious tradition
um i think that it might have been
actually more complicated uh for deb's
had he actually been a believer because
you think about martin luther king the
core of king's
um uh uh uh strength and power came from
the fact
that he shared a faith with the very
people
that they and they were mo
who were active in the civil rights
movement they were marching together i
mean the core of that movement is really
not
is really grounded in the in the black
baptist tradition of the south
uh and it's i don't it's not so much
that a religious person couldn't have
been effective if it had debs been
religious um but
what was true then and in some ways is
still true now although differently but
certainly what was true then was is that
the religious
the symbols of them of what
the sociologist robert bella would later
call
a
civic religion but the symbols of a kind
of a broad non-denominational religious
faith
were were spread widely throughout the
culture and and deb's that that's what
deb's really tapped into
um and it's not that he you know
i mean it became it was a source for him
but it it was not a source that he would
have connected to a
uh to a given
either religious group sociologically
speaking or certainly not to a religious
faith king made another was able to go
beyond the religious faith issue that is
he could speak to people who were not of
that tradition and speak very
effectively but clearly his
his foundation uh especially in the
early years really was indeed out of
that tradition
what were the main activities he went
through when he was young that began to
gain him this kind of popularity and
attention was it running for political
office or participating in strikes or
giving speeches and then who funded him
and how did he
yeah well what what debs did was
um
he was with the brotherhood of
locomotive firemen uh through most
through the 1980s
and um he traveled so he had a salaried
position in fact he had a white collar
position he was no longer working the
railroad he was actually a uh
uh uh a bureaucrat if you will i mean he
was the executive secretary national
secretary treasurer actually of the of
the union of the brotherhood um but what
i think what won him
much much of his
following amongst working people
was that for 10 12 years he traveled the
country
of building their brotherhoods
working with them helping them to handle
issues uh at the uh
uh with their company with the uh issues
that would make or could not evolve into
a strike
um
those that commitment was really pretty
deep that he had and it also was
reciprocated however when it came to
making the transition to socialism
most of those working people never
followed him
to
into socialism for them they he even
debs was not able to
articulate powerfully enough or
effectively enough
the bridge he envisioned between
that uh his grounding in the terre haute
of the 1870s
and the realities of a more corporate
society and its difficulties and and the
implications for that um
so uh
in in that way um there was a a gap in
and and that ended up for him that the
gap in expectations or between
expectation and reality ended up for him
when he was in prison in atlanta in in
the early 1920s a period of really
intense and profound depression uh
because as uh he once pointed out rather
bitterly uh with a bitter sarcasm that
um he was uh
brought to atlanta federal penitentiary
on a train run by men who were members
of the very unions he had organized 40
years before
and so that was a painful yes sir yeah
i'm wondering um debs was a socialist he
was a uniquely american socialist but
what is he a marxist and what contact
did he have with people and ideas from
europe from other places
uh
my
my best best and that best sense of it
is this
um deb's actually read read marks uh at
least some of mark's in german and he
was fluent in german and french um
but
debs was never a marxist uh and in fact
that's what drove his more orthodox
comrades absolutely crazy uh because uh
he was really talking out of a deeply
grounded populist tradition in america
um that understood
both the power of those democratic
traditions
and use the the the um
the language of them and us use the
language of elites versus the people
okay
um
his marxism uh he he um
i don't think he ever read
marx uh but i can't i can't prove that i
know he read parts of but i don't i
don't think he ever really sat down and
studied marx the
the um
the most
obvious time he might have done that
would have been in woodstock jail
actually when one of his comrades comes
and gives him or somebody's trying to
organize him into the socialist party
because he's not officially a socialist
then victor berger from milwaukee comes
and gives him uh three volumes of the
three volumes of das capital and
my bet is that they remained unopened
essentially but uh
but he uh so he his groundedness was
less he did he did have access and in
some interchange
with some european socialists he did
read some of the more popular pamphlets
uh but he he he was not a scholar you
know or not uh he was not going to be
sitting down and reading martial yeah uh
i i'd like to uh return a little bit to
the religious and evangelical language
and ask you um
what impact do you think
either
the
religious language
or religion itself
had on the content
of his
messages one might argue for example
that it's designed either just to
broaden right um the appeal or that it's
furniture
uh or that it's uh rhetoric that's drawn
from his own background without having
any impact on
the content of his message could you
comment on that i think that's actually
the almost the flip side of the the last
question in a funny way because
um
in
avoiding or not embracing in any
structural way marxism
debs did have the problem of how does he
legitimize
n i don't mean this as a uh his dissent
i don't by legitimize here i don't mean
uh in a functionalist way how did he how
did he uh
find some explanation in case anybody
asked but really inside of himself how
how did he understand himself to himself
one element of that was in fact
um the um
the declaration the constitution those
traditional american political values
the other phrase which i didn't mention
in my talk but the other phrase that is
ubiquitous throughout
almost every speech he keeps on going
back to the brotherhood of man and he
begins to talk about that in a broad
non-faith way
numbers he's not he's not a religious
person in that sense at all but in a way
that again
evokes us
in him a sense of some divine spirit
some divine being some power
that indeed
when he said when he evokes that power
to bless america when he evokes that
power to uh to talk about um
uh the the the the um
uh
uh
the value of those individuals in the
audience um
as part of this coming brotherhood of
man which is very un
social certainly on marxist and uns that
was more than just a technique for him
that was something he actually deeply
believed he took from the
romanticism if you will oddly enough of
the enlightenment as he understood it
through his father and through victor
hugo and eugenie sue those two novelists
especially he took from that this this
kind of amorphous sense
of a larger religious sensibility
that was not for him not necessarily in
conflict with reason but nonetheless was
another dimension to it
um it's hard to pin it
mainly because it doesn't have a
overt
uh connection to either a religious
tradition certainly not to a religious
practice
um
but for him the embrace of the christ
figure was not just that atlanta in 1922
but it permeates it's another theme an
image that permeates his
his
his uh
talking his speeches and that becomes a
way for him to to actually
um uh
express part of a larger
uh
sensibility political sensibility that
he in fact has that's how i've i've come
to understand him
yeah uh yes sir
this is conjecture of course but where
are you live today
how do you think he would see the the
country this democratic process that he
had such great faith in and the idea was
to certainly
that's a great question it's really a
great question
um well i think first uh he would have a
wry smile we're all in imagination now
but he would have a wry smile and he
would say so things don't change you
know
uh that in fact there are still a
handful of folks relatively speaking who
are saying this is what it means to be
patriotic this is what it means to be
american and anything else is borders on
treason
so i think that that would be one of the
things that he would see quite quickly i
also think however that he would be
depressed
at the transformation
in the larger in the political culture
from a time when he actually could
honestly engage
could talk publicly without
embarrassment about the power and
meaning of democratic values uh
as expressed and and
and and exercised by an individual
and
whether one you know and and the way in
which our political debate
and discussion and in many ways
involvement seems to have
descended and has spiraled in a
different direction certainly in the
last 30 or 40 years or so
i think that that would have probably
depressed him so it wouldn't have just
been the focus on the elites but he
would have really said what's happened
what's happened to us as a as a nation
as a people how do we they used to have
two-hour discussion to have a debate i
mean there was no tv there was no radio
so you went to a political talk you were
there for two to three hours
and somebody better have something to
say
uh or else they're gonna be leaving in
droves um but we don't have that anymore
and we don't have i mean we don't have
that certainly in our national campaigns
we you know for both the democrats and
the republicans recently we just saw the
you know that there are little snippets
in these these public uh discussions or
debates as they're called um but also we
don't we don't have that in our civic
culture anywhere near to the extent that
we might have had it uh a hundred years
ago i think that would have been up
depressing or upsetting
sir yeah the thing that strikes me is
that
this man is you know concerned about the
the general public and the welfare of
the the general public
and
given the you know the rise of
concentration of power which we've seen
that becomes a little more and more
hopeless to
have any
anyone speak for the general public how
are you ma'am well yeah i mean you could
say that that you know debs like so many
of us that you know never never read as
max weber and never understood
bureaucracies and etc etc and that's
that sense of that concentration of
power i think that's true
um
i
i
cannot obviously i mean i don't think
one can say what debs would have thought
today
at all
but i do think that the problem you
raise is a serious one in that how do
you
find if
in our time that bridge between
us as individuals and a broader sense of
a common good if you will
appropriate for our time
when it seems as if
the
it seems as if the levers
of power are so contained
and
compressed into a small segment of the
population whether we're talking
economic or indeed political as well
and i i don't have an answer for that uh
uh and i i again i really don't know
what
how how i i
presume since he was sensitive to these
issues in his own time he would have
been sensitive to them now uh he didn't
have an answer really in his own time i
mean as i said there was a naivete about
his ultimate solutions uh concerning um
uh the nature of the corporations and
welcoming cooper you know seeing
corporations as laying the groundwork
for the socialist commonwealth
that was quite
um
utopian
so
yeah tina what influenced you to write
the book about debs
oh that's
well for me um i um
i am a child of the 1960s
and i
finished
the 1960s if you will uh
really deeply concerned about the
direction that what was called in this
broad amorphous term the new left was
taking i
i found i
before i knew this about debs i knew in
myself
that i was profoundly american i was
proud to be an american but i was not
going to allow people to define for me
what that meant it didn't mean in my
case therefore you support the war in
vietnam it didn't mean therefore that
you support segregation or jim crow it
didn't mean a whole series of things um
and so i decided that i i myself was
concerned
and and and about whether there had was
given the way in which the 1960s ended
in
some disarray
whether
whether there was in fact a dissenting
tradition
in this society that
had legs had strength and so through a
process that
it's i make i'm going to make it sound
far more direct than it was but over a
couple of years
i ended up i had gone to berkeley to
study uh actually african american
history and i did
uh but on the way to my dissertation i i
gene debs came back and he was a way for
me to begin to think through some of the
broader issues of the 1960s
because what i vowed to do was to look
at debs as i called it at the time warts
and all i mean i didn't want to create
some some biography of a saint i wanted
to do a real serious study of both the
individual
and the meaning of dissent and it's it's
it's validity and it's if you will it's
it's it's it's substance
uh in american life and that's what what
propelled me in the in the process i i
learned an awful lot about gene debs
that i didn't know and i i my my
understanding of him actually grew and
my admiration for him grew even as my
criticism of them in the book is really
quite sharp uh because there were a
whole series of places where he he uh
uh just really made
so what motivated me first was really a
very individual personal
quest if you will and wanting to
understand
and but i i insisted that that would be
the core that i would in encase that or
operate
through that uh in a very in a serious
and ultimately scholarly way as i could
so that i i wouldn't create a
a false
that wouldn't do me or
bad history really doesn't make for very
good politics so yeah so
aaron
um i just want to pick up on that last
question and ask well
a question about the devs book but also
about your work in general which is all
biographical
given your interest in descent
why do you think you wound up focusing
on individuals as opposed to say writing
a couple of books about social movements
in general
or more broadly if you if you want to
maybe just say a few words about your
vision of the rel the general
relationship between biography and
history
okay
well
i ended up i think focusing on
individuals
really because of the second part of
your question
it strikes me that while very good work
is done writing about social movements
of all sorts of different kinds and and
cultural issues etc no question about it
it seems to me
that well let me put it this way what
most excites me as i think about history
is what an individual does
with
the society and the culture they inherit
that they don't make they don't create
that is theirs by birth for better and
for worse
and what happens there what what's part
of that trans that interaction
um
and so in part
i i always begin
thinking about a biography
by thinking about the theme or the topic
i want to the issues i want to explore
uh i don't start with the individual i
start with so there is a very serious
social dimension to all of my
biographies but i'm absolutely intrigued
by the interplay between the broader
social and political context
and any given individual uh the very
first line of the introduction in the
deb's book says this is a social
biography of of eugene victor debs and i
i i chose that phrase social biography
very very purposefully because it really
and i go on to explain maybe a little
ham-handedly but nonetheless i go on to
explain what i mean by that in a sense
that is exactly this interplay of the
individual and the larger social forces
because in some ways what i'm actually
looking for is both a to to understand
more clearly
the possibilities of
transcending
transcending the wrong word the
possibilities of changing and
through interaction with those larger
forces and also understanding the power
simultaneously of those larger and it's
in that play
so and that's one thing the second thing
is that when you come down to it
when an individual says
uh
i forgot her name but i just read about
it in the paper a couple days ago a
woman in montgomery alabama black woman
in montgomery alabama in 1951
she went to the front of the bus
and demanded to get a transfer to get to
to another
bus line well african-americans weren't
allowed to do that
and
and she was arrested and she said in an
interview just recently and that's where
i read in the paper she said she said if
you don't stand up for your rights
sometime when are you going to do it
well that's an individual mrs parks a
few years later again that's an
individual decision
and that's really powerful it doesn't
mean that it's separate it doesn't mean
it's isolated from larger community and
other discussions going on but that that
intrigues me
and so yeah
sir
i'm just curious uh
during the uh deb's life uh
his contemporaries was there anybody
that he admired or looked up to himself
hmm
uh
there was that he he had uh a lot of
two parts of his career before the
pullman strike before 1894 he actually
had a lot of good friends uh most almost
all men not all of them but almost all
men uh in
in this trade union work across the
nation
um they were drinking buddies they were
uh in that very much in that male
culture
um
but he also uh looked up to people like
jane adams uh he uh
wrote some editorials about her and and
i don't know that he ever had any
extensive i don't think he may have met
her but he didn't have a real friendship
with her
um
after pullman after he begins he really
becomes the the national figure
deb's
debs found it difficult
to divest himself of that celebrity
status
he would begin to demand uh
things from his
co-workers in the movement uh that they
treat him in a certain way or that they
you know make certain that certain
things were there when he he was
arriving or things of that nature um
he wasn't haughty in in in a fundamental
way but he he became much more he began
to
impart believe a little bit what was
being written about him
um so he his deepest and closest
friendship was with his his brother
theodore
and then in the
decade before during and after world war
one um mabel dunlap curry who was his
closest the
friend we
don't know exactly the full nature of
the relationship
but
from about 1914 on and
and they were the two really the closest
closest people to him he had a lot of
comrades a lot of people he talked
socialist party business with and things
of that nature
uh and he loved to go drinking and so he
had but those were the two really the
closest people i think beyonce
yeah oh okay um understanding that we
have to look at it in the context of his
times did he take any stand on race
issues was he asked to
yeah he actually did in fact the
socialist party thanks that's a great
question the socialist party
in fact was really
divided on this uh there was a major
wing of the party uh that was profoundly
racist explicitly racist not not i mean
talking about
victor berger the milwaukee
leader
talked in wrote editorials about the uh
the threat from the blackmail rapist
imagined in his head but there you go
um the socialists in the south and the
southwest who were in fact such an
important part of an evangelical
movement and for a brief period of time
of of a socialist movement as well
uh excluded african-americans
universally
absolutely no you know organizing gene
debs when he's in maybe one way to talk
about it when gene debs is giving a talk
in mobile alabama about 19
or 405 somewhere around there he walks
in it's organized by the socialist party
and they have a uh
um
they've rented a hall or whatever
he walks in and he sees that it's jim
crow that there's a section for blacks
and a section for whites he says i
refuse to go out on that stage until
this is integrated
and
when birth of a nation came out in 1916
an ex again a a cecil b demille's
technically brilliant brilliant film uh
but a overtly racist analysis which was
dominant at the time
on the issue of reconstruction after the
american civil war about um
uh uh
uh uh uh
um
talking about how the free the freed men
and women the former former slaves uh
were buffoons and were destroying the
the principles of american government
and all this sort of stuff um debs
joined the protest that was ultimately
led he didn't join the naacp but was
ultimately led by the naacp against that
and wrote letters
protesting the the
especially when woodrow wilson uh showed
it at the white house
so
uh he had a very different analysis
and a very different approach he grew up
and this is another part this is one of
the things i learned about him that uh
one of the
example of this the growth in the guy
uh i i ended up not agreeing with many
of his strategic understandings and all
of that but
but he grew up in the essentially
southern culture of terre haute indiana
uh racial jokes were the the
with the coin of the realm
uh the black community in terre haute
was segregated into a very small uh uh
part of town
uh very few were allowed to vote this is
in the 1870s
so debs grew up that way in the same way
that he grew up with a very
individual a very isolated sense of
individualism
but he what one of the things that is mo
to me was most encouraging about him and
this may go back to that sense of
um
why i do find it intriguing to focus on
individuals because
i was i'm marveled at the way he changed
and as i began to understand some of the
process
through which he changed and because he
changed and did seek to find others who
changed along in in different but yet
similar ways
he was able then to make he and they
together were able to make a broader
impact than than if it had just been
gene debs
um
that's
that that and and he he did that on race
as well he really changed fundamentally
and understanding uh of where he came
from
oh that was your question i'm sorry okay
you could uh press that just a little
farther i mean as you know we a month
ago or so there was a michael cayden
came and spoke about uh his biography of
william jennings brian and indeed uh his
presentation on
his impressed uh discussion of brian's
life in your discussion of devs life
today point up so many interesting
parallels between those two figures they
were you know superficially similar they
were populists they were charismatic
they were religious in the in the
rhetoric that they used uh but but brian
was consistently racist from the
beginning to the end the end of his life
and when people in that occasion tried
to sort of press a little bit and say
well but why how do you deal with that
contradiction
um and i suppose the simple answer there
is what contradiction you know
black people were black people and the
rest of us were you know
you know working for the and then
there's a there's a very very good
historian by the name of george
federickson
who
wrote some years ago a uh uh an analysis
of american racism
uh and he he
ultimately ended up with a concept that
he calls heron voc democracy
and that he what he means by that using
the german what he means by that is is
that certainly through the civil war if
not indeed through
a major portion of jim crow as well
that many proponents of american
democratic values in the white community
north as well as south not just southern
at all
understood the meaning of that
democratic promise
as in fact only including
white the white community it was never
intended and indeed if you go back and
look at the constitution you can see
that in the original constitution there
was indeed a three-fifths what's called
the three-fifths compromise that
actually created a separate political
status for blacks
so
uh yeah
bob
i'm
interested in your points about the
corporate uh the view of the corporation
i suppose a competing idea at the same
time was that um that a democratic
government can regulate corporations
that you you don't really need the sort
of movement that he was
dealing with or proposing what was his
view of that sort of
alternative view at the same time
um he worked with progressives would be
that that alternative view he worked
with people with people who call
themselves progressives and then
uh uh
later with people who are beginning to
organize around a progressive party he
did not work with theodore roosevelt uh
with the bull moose party as uh but
um but ultimately he thought the
analysis was deeply inadequate uh he
argued that what was really needed was
to transform
uh the very uh structure not the
structure but to transform the direction
in which that power would be used that
regulation ultimately would be avoided
circum circumvented and the like that
what was needed really was to if you had
a democratic socialist
government in office that was actually
responsible to the people all of this is
framed in in in
in that context um then
the the um
the
the power within the workplace might be
more equitably distributed between
owners managers and the workforce
and the issue of pricing profit and cost
to consumers and all of that related
material
could be his theoretically thought could
be in fact
a more
justly adjudicated more justly
established um
in the democratic socialism that he was
considering
we've never really seen that
uh it's very different from what the
soviet union emerged into uh
and in fact he becomes very sharply
critical of the soviet union by
1922-1923
okay
yeah
what was his
vision of uh of this
of this aspect when he was disappointed
when socialism failed
well he um he had a very painful post
atlanta experi atlanta penitentiary
experience
uh that is um
he
when he got his health back uh he went
back out on the road
again naively assuming that gene debs
was still gene debs uh but he wasn't he
wasn't himself he was sick he was much
older he the the the two and a half
years in prison had taken its toll
um secondly um the world had changed the
bolshevik revolution uh was one event uh
world war one
and the uh ultimately uh the uh
uh the the the the treaty of versailles
and the whole transformation of uh
emergence of a a new kind of american
consciousness about the world i guess uh
had changed
and
he didn't have a new he he didn't have a
message that made sense i mean one of
a
his
a a socialist who adored him
um
wrote a letter to a friend that i read
and said you know i went to a deb's
speech and i i it was painful
it was painful
uh because he he didn't have the the
either the ideas to galvanize nor the
strength
to to engage
um
and so he never lived to see
uh
the socialist movement was never a
majority movement obviously but he never
lived to see its real uh the eclipse of
it uh because he died in 1926
uh but he
did have to experience and live through
his
personal sense of
uh inadequacy on the on on the platform
where he had achieved some of his
greatest moments
during that the course of his
disappointment and during his later
years
didn't uh wasn't there any
uh
uh
followers that could take over the
reigns and and well there was and and
indeed it's uh it the the rain is the
the the the the crown if you will is
passed to norman thomas
who uh it gives is a pro
i mean talk about the connections with
religion i mean is a former presbyterian
minister uh and a social gospeler and a
progressive uh who has himself
morphed if you will changed into
uh a socialist and norman thomas leads
the party from 1926 he's one of the
folks who gives the eulogy at debs his
funeral in 1926. he leads the party from
1926 into the middle of the 1960s when a
young a young guy by the name of mike
harrington michael harrington
essentially assumes the leadership of
the socialist party and then ultimately
the
social the democratic socialists of
america in the eighteen eight mike is
now dead
thank you very much and uh we've uh uh
we're about run out of time but thank
you all very much for for coming and for
your questions
eugene v debs citizen and socialist
the first edition of this book was
published in 1982 and was the recipient
of the bancroft prize and the american
historical association's john h dunning
prize in u.s history
nick salvatore is a professor of
american studies at cornell university
and author of we all got history the
memory books of amos weber for more
visit nick salvatore.com